[Musique]
pas de jean-françois
62 ans
je suis conseiller départemental du
canton c'est un canton qui est composé
de plusieurs quartiers saint bernard la
montagne 8e la grande chaloupe la petite
fille bas-de-la-rivière la colle et le
centre-ville aussi le quartier de marca
tv de joigny
tu es là
j'ai grandi dans mon contrat j'ai fait
des études d'un mot quand on est aussi
j'ai travaillé à la poste au centre
ville de saverne
[Musique]
la première la proximité
m
l'action du département dans les
quartiers au plus près de ceux qui ont
besoin et remettent en place toutes les
permanences d'assistants et
d'intervenants sociaux du département
dans ces cas sauf la première la
deuxième
c'est sur les dispositifs
simplifiée
toile été renforcées communiqué et
vulgariser les dispositifs
du département notamment les maisons
d'accueil familial le maf les maisons
d'assistantes maternelles l'énam le tage
tremplin pour l'activité des jeunes le
passé
et aussi les amap
association pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne
[Musique]
bon mutualisent les politiques publiques
région département communes cc et dans
les
les relations
départements communes ccf on a un outil
le pst le paquet sur ip soudas était
territoriales le pack de six villas et
territoriales qui va nous permettre de
renforcer les moyens et répondre aux
défis de demain kisa par le département
sa compétence première c'est le social
et aujourd'hui nous sommes nous
subissions une kraft et
sanitaires qui va déboucher sur une
crise sociale donc département eyrolles
important donc le soutien des
réunionnais et notamment des plus
défavorisés